oh [__] it's Monday the 22nd I hope
you're ready to [__] rock I'm
late but who gives a Frenchman's [__]
the intention is still there you
understand me it's Monday and that's all
you need to know trying to strap on a
[__] pair and let these [__]
know that you're taking it to the next
goddamn level you understand me if
you're not gonna do that take a bus
[__] uncle Joey here looking like
[__] Filip Leonardo over there and
180 first street throwing [__] heat I
want to thank everybody who came out to
the stress factor into the power
Providence comedy connection last week I
had a great time with you
some girl brought me some [__] banana
cake some [__] white chocolate chip I
mean listen rats
stress factory you were phenomenal I
love you but that was then this is now
it's a whole new [__] week grab
your ball salute the flag and let these
[__] know that you're here if
you don't let them know you're here
nobody gonna do it for you ain't got no
[__] publish this here I'm saying but
we got some tremendous weeds today this
is [__] Walker from the Armenians over
that sunset Oval Office Burbank
Boulevard the best and I got this over
here the [__] master you understand
me that [__] makes you put on a George
Washington wig and with black people and
[__] like that
anyway we got to get out of jail free
card from the [__] DEA that's
how we roll you follow I'm saying Thea I
know people I've been telling you my
[__] for years let's do another bowl
of this [__] tooth roots and let's
get down here because we don't [__]
around
I got nothing this week I got Saturday
night you've sold out at the ice house
and then I'm just working on that half
hour for you [__] for Netflix
just keep putting it down putting it
down putting it down I want to make you
guys proud I want to make you guys say
you know what cuz listen it wasn't me
who got me out
Netflix it was you [__] who got
me a necklace because you're torching
them you told them we ain't [__]
around no more we want to uncle Joey on
there we want them now you following me
so want to thank you guys so because of
that I got to do a good job for you so I
might every night bang it out two weeks
before the special comes out we'll have
video footages for you every Monday like
matte flavors world old-school were
taking it back with taking it back
[__] [__] tremendous I love
smoking marijuana what you guys you guys
are my favorite [__] people in the
world without you and have you got any
way I'm stoned
the DEA [__] Jeff Sessions you know I'm
saying [__] Jeff Sessions Jeff Sessions
shows up or we I tell that [__]
step back funky cat and I got a number
for you to call in the back you see I'm
saying once you got the number in the
back even let him handcuff you and go
take my wallet out [__] before you
put me in the trunk take the take the
wallet out it's to your best [__] that
information that you take the wallet
they'll take the wallet they see the
caught up on top who do you know I don't
know nobody you just read the car you
don't see no names no names
oh the smell of reefer in the afternoon
it's like napalm for some people you
follow me anyway
we got nothing we're gonna take the
special on take some time off you know
when you do what you know you in the
world series what do you do you're gonna
[__] and then you land I'm going in any
land with mercy and my wife for a few
days we're gonna hang out like [__]
white people and then what else am i
doing I'm doing the collusive Casino on
the 17th and that's it for June and then
in July in Las Vegas again at the South
Point I got Utah at Salt Lake City the
last weekend of June that's all you got
then two weeks later I'm in Kansas City
Mo what are you [__] nuts I'm coming
back they got things fixed over there
last time I was dead a guy had [__]
sticky fingers they moved them they
moves another guy in now we're ready to
[__] rock you follow me
so we're here we're coming out I'm
trying to get into better shape I'm
trying to drop down a fighting weight
just in case somebody drop something has
to be open I go in and take two punches
to the head and get the small milk and
that's it you know me dawg plain and
simple I'm him you don't see no posse
you don't see how nothing uncle Joey
solo we show up solo [__] tremendous
let's give this master a shot what do
you think do the master Oh tip-top Magoo
on a Monday
guys listen if you ain't tip-top bug on
a Monday your whole workweek is gonna be
ruined
I need your mind in the right place I
need you're writing down your goals I
think you're doing your 22 push-ups and
always remember to go out of your way
and make somebody's day Saturday night
in the show I had an edible [__]
burner all my pocket I split it in half
and I gave it to a guy in the front row
I made this day that's how you do things
you make somebody's day that's what
being a real Christians about making
somebody's day was a big [__] deal
and they I'm not even a Christian it's
like a jeet kune do-- of religion you
follow me alone I got a little [__]
Buddhism a little Catholicism a little
Santeria I borrow a little bit from the
Jews that was the Jewish book the
cabassa whatever the [__] they call it I
don't know nothing I'm saying I don't
ask questions I just read and I look at
the I look straight down let's smoke
this [__] master I want to see
[__] I got [__] to doing people to
see I gotta go to Weight Watchers
tonight and weigh in hopefully I don't
show up like Mackenzie [__] done
seven ounces over and then we got the
[__] podcast coming out to you
tonight's new name of the podcast is
[__] revenge you gonna love it you're
gonna [__] love it you understand me
you're gonna love it anyway that's it
and that's that I hope you got your
tickets for June 4th in Las Vegas as
part of the church family you know you
know I need you there even if you don't
get it I need you outside breaking a
window lighting the fire doing something
this is big for the church this is big
for all people like you and me people
have been to prison people been down and
we [__] came up I don't know how we
made it we came up and I wanna [__]
Netflix I was in a Cell dog I used to
take a [__] and they found other [__]
people other people anyway some
shoutouts and my man Timmy Holloway I
hope his dad's doing better over there
in Secaucus Timmy's the getaway driving
my brother I love with the dead Dennis
Colangelo came out a bunch of [__]
people from North Bergen came out this
week and there were a fire to the stress
factory a smoke on a joke what's with
the [__] history I don't give a [__]
smoke the ball or shut your [__] pie
hole alright I'm alright alright
oh I think I'm gonna go out and listen
to a [__] long run by the Eagles and
do a little work I got a little meeting
here in a couple minutes
yeah don't [__] with me I got
credentials don't even think about a DEA
tap in my [__] periscope why I'm
saying anyway I love you [__]
with all my I do the right thing if you
use and stop today it's over if you're
using today
that's it today's the last day go get a
bag of weed smoke weed watch youtube
videos and stop using so I can opiates
whatever the [__] you're doing you know
I'm saying I got a couple xanax here
listen you need a metal your anxiety got
a Papa's antic just to keep the [__]
tiger down from time to time do what you
need to do you know I'm saying but you
can't beat those other ones I don't [__]
you up how do I know cuz I've been there
anyway I love you [__] tonight
at seven o'clock the Church of what's
happening now from my heart you know we
do it there's no fakeness here this is a
radio voice nothing oh yes ooh column
india maintaining did my magic toilet on
go why are they bomb walloping is wrote
a guru how all I see jessicaho evil I
Santissima category eat or battle I up a
little safer anyway I said that's that
you know I love your [__] with
all my heart
see you guys tonight seven o'clock thank
you for checking it have a good day
don't let nobody [__] with you Bergen
County and then out don't let nobody
[__] with you
I'm the uncle Joey sent you and listen
the dream is a [__] reality you're
watched it you watched it in front of
you the last couple years so tell them
on a suck a big you [__] them breaking
down walls you stab important whatever
the [__] you need to do you gotta do
today you follow me I love you I can get
them tell them or to suck your dick does
at the end of the day they're gonna suck
your dick